PAUL SAXMAN: Hello, and
welcome to Google Maps
Developer Shortcuts.
I'm Paul Saxman, and this week
is our premiere episode of our
shortcut series.
We're going to try to teach
tips, tricks, and techniques
for building beautiful,
compelling, useful maps in
about five minutes or less.
So that's actually the show
is five minutes or less.
It might take you a couple
minutes longer to get your map
up and running, but
that's the show.
So with that, this week what
we're going to do is we're
going to talk about getting
Google Drive data into a
Google Map, and if we have time
we'll do the inverse--
try to get a Google Map
into a Google Drive.
So we can go both ways, one or
the other, but let's start
with the easy one.
So if we go over to my
spreadsheet here, you can see
that I have a spreadsheet
of about 10 cities.
That's column A. Column B, I
have populations, and C and D
is longitude and latitude.
I got this data from the Natural
Earth data set which
publishes all kinds of
geographic data we talked
about in some preview shows.
Getting that into drive in
this spreadsheet, just a
matter of cutting and pasting.
If you have a lot more data,
though, getting into drive--
different techniques
can apply.
But the technique here that
I want to teach today is
actually building a web service
using Google Drive to
serve this data to a map.
So the first thing I'm going to
do is I'm going to go over
to Tools and Script Manager.
And you can see here I have
a couple scripts already.
If you don't have these scripts,
which you won't the
first time you run this, you
just hit the New button.
I'm going to say start with--
you can either start with a
script as a web app or just a
blank project.
I'm going to start with blank
project, because, actually,
building these web apps
is really simple.
And then you're ready to go
actually editing your script.
But I'm going to actually
start with the one I
already worked on.
So you can see a few
things here.
I have a couple of constants
at the top.
The spreadsheet ID-- that
actually comes from over on my
spreadsheet.
If I close this window, that
spreadsheet ID is actually in
the browser bar up at the top.
So you can copy that out
for this script.
Sheet name--
this is called data.
Actually, this is what I called
the sheet here down at
the bottom.
By default, it's called sheet
one or something like that.
You just actually click
on the little down
arrow and rename it.
These are two important steps--
getting your key and
naming your sheet.
Next thing is you're going to
want to create a doGet get
function and take a
request object.
So here I'm actually using the
request object, getting
parameters out, and getting
JSONP, which is one of the
parameters that I'm
going to pass in
later to this web service.
So that is actually the callback
that I'm passing into
the web service.
And here what I'm doing is
actually getting the data out
of my sheet.
So here I'm using
the spreadsheet
app, opening by ID.
I'm taking the spreadsheet
ID that ended up here.
Get sheet by name, I'm using
data which was a sheet that I
named earlier, and
get data range.
So this is the range object now
that I'm getting out of
this call here.
Next is I'm going to stringify
into JSON the values from that
spreadsheet.
So here I'm doing range
dot get values.
I'm passing that into this JSON
stringify method, and
then I'm wrapping that into
JSONP function call.
So I'm using my callback,
which is the method I'm
passing in, or will be passing
into the request, and wrapping
that in parentheses, because
this is actually a function
call, a JavaScript function
call, that
I'll be using later.
And very last line here, what
I'm doing is I'm just taking
that JSON output, creating
this text output object,
setting the MIME type to
JSON, and returning
from this doGet method.
This down here is just
some testing code.
If you want to actually
run this--
create a function like this to
run it, you can get the output
in the logs just for some
eyeballs testing.
Once you have such a script
together, the next thing
you're going to want
to do is go to
file and manage versions.
So what here you're going to do
is name a version for your
application--
name your version and
save a new version.
So I didn't make any changes,
so I'm not going
to save a new one.
You can see I have about five
versions already, though.
Or I have had five
versions already.
We'll close that.
Once you've saved the version,
you can go over to this little
arrow here in the cloud, which
is deploy as a web app, or you
can also hit the Publish
button and also
deploy as web app.
If you haven't already deployed
it, I believe you
just get the bottom part here.
So you pick a project version,
which was the version that we
created earlier, executable as
me, and what you're going to
want to do is you're going to
make anyone, even anonymous,
can actually execute your app.
Once you do this, be careful,
because once this is up and
running anybody can actually
extract that data using this
web service from your
spreadsheet.
So that's it.
So once we do all those tricks--
so let me go back
here, deploy as a web app.
I already have this running, so
I'm just going to say give
me my latest code.
You can see that I get a URL
here, and this actually
returns the data in JSON
in my spreadsheet.
Here I'm getting undefined
because I didn't actually pass
in the JSONP.
Very last thing, so you're going
to want to copy this
script line out here, because
this is what you're actually
going to paste into
your map code.
Now I'm going to go over
to some map code.
I'm going to paste in this data
services URL, which was
the one that I just made, or
that I just copied out.
I'm going to add a
JSONP parameter.
So this is the callback
function.
So callback is actually my
JSONP callback in my map
JavaScript.
I'm initializing a map here.
Here's a little tricky bit.
So after I've initialized the
map, I'm actually going to
create a script tag, pass in the
data services URL, which
is the URL to this web service
that's running in Google
Drive, and then I'm actually
going to append this object to
the head of my DOM tree.
And that's actually going
to execute the
script that this JSON--
it's actually going to call
the JSONP service.
And then I have a callback
function.
I'm getting the data back.
This is just a--
we saw the JSON before.
It's actually just an
array of an array.
So I'm actually creating a
marker for each of the
lat-long points that are
in this spreadsheet.
That's pretty much it.
And then there's a little bit of
map canvas code down here.
So it's a very simple
application.
And if we go over to what the
end product looks like, I'm
just running this on locally,
so if I reload this, this is
the code that I just showed
a minute ago.
You'd see all these points
rendered on a
map from Google Drive.
Just to prove the concept, if I
go back over here, let's say
I want to get rid of all
but one of these.
I could just delete those
out, spreadsheet saved.
I go back to my awesome map.
I reload it, and all I
have is Japan now.
So this is a great way you can
create dynamic data or create
a spreadsheet, share it with
other people that can actually
change the data, dynamically
changing the map.
Really great use case there.
I'm out of time, so today I'm
not going to cover actually
getting your Google Map into
Google Drive, but we'll cover
that in another episode.
So if you have any questions
about the show, if you have
any other ideas for future
shows, let me know.
And, yeah-- just post them in
the comments of the YouTube
stream or on Google+ With that,
we'll see you next week.